une question à la une de l'actualité la
carte bancaire est elle vraiment le
moyen le plus sûr de paiement au monde
la question devient de plus en plus
polémique n'arrive is lebranchu se voit
obligé cet après-midi d'organiser une
grande réunion de concertation avec le
développement du commerce sur internet
les fraudes se multiplient en cas
d'infraction ce sont les commerçants qui
doivent payer six ris de veau grégoire
aux in a
acheté sur internet un caméscope
numérique par exemple très facile il
suffit de mentionner un nom vrai ou faux
une adresse vraie ou fausse et de taper
un numéro de carte bancaire à 16
chiffres avec sa date d'expiration
le code secret à quatre chiffres n'est
pas demandée dans la vente par
correspondance
résultat avec une carte volée n'importe
quel fraudeur peut faire ses courses à
distance
question guillermo vent de la hi fi
vidéo et de l'électroménager sur
internet son premier travail flairer les
commandes suspecte exemple une commande
de deux caméscopes et bon paiement par
carte bancaire donc on vérifiera quand
on aura reçues de ficher carte bancaire
si c'est une vraie carte bancaire n'est
enfin là c'est quelque chose sur lequel
les collaborateurs du service
consommateurs vont quand même un petit
peu tiqué en cas de doute un seul moyen
de vérification interroger les banques
sur la validité de la carte bancaire
celle ci par exemple est refusé ce qui
veut dire que la carte bancaire n'est
pas a été dérobée soit n'a pas le
montant la provision nécessaire pour
faire cette transaction donc on est
forcé d'annuler cette projection les
commerçants pas toujours très vigilant
sont trompés par les voleurs sur
internet on trouve par exemple tout
l'arsenal des pirates pour fabriquer de
faux numéros de cartes bancaires plus
vrai que nature des algorithmes des
formules à l' usage des fameux hacker il
existe aussi une autre méthode volée
directement les listings de cartes
bancaires dans les sites de commerce
électronique mal sécurisés il n'y a pas
de sécurité à 100% de même qu'il n'ya
pas d' attaque imparable assez
simplement bien souvent s'ils
n'attaquent se produire ici la taxe se
réalise c'est parce qu'il ya bien
souvent insouciance ou méconnaissance de
l'administrateur du site par rapport à
la taxe si vous vous apercevez qu'on a
utilisé votre numéro de carte bancaire
pour payer sur internet signé le à votre
banquier il est obligé de vous
rembourser c'est le commerçant qui
endossera la responsabilité en cas de
fraude est un